doch wird präsentiert vom neuen toyota
rav 4 4 x 4 und hybrid die ideale
kombination für die schweiz
[Musik]
ich hätte die zwischen luft war ich mehr
sind die entweder eine zustimmung wie
normal ist der normalzustand wie sie
einst komplett verloren
der morgen gefängnis kalt und dann
komplett
während der sonnen druck kommen wenn sie
zehn politiker hätten mir ich will raus
konzern bestätigte jetzt motiviert aber
mit mir die familie wieder aufbauen
das wäre gut
[Musik]
auf der tasse bis daraus gelernt das
klappte nicht wie dieser sagt macht das
ist eine lehre sie aber das ist alles
am späten nachmittag des ersten januar
2015 fuhren björn und christine kaiser
so schnell sie konnten nach flach im
kanton zürich ihre tochter nathalie
hatte kurz davor ihre beiden kinder
getötet
ein zweijähriges mädchen und einen
fünfjährigen jungen weil sie nicht
wollte dass die kleinen zurück ins heim
müssen
das familiendrama in flach war auslöser
einer landesweiten empörung über die
kest die kinder und erwachsenenschutz
behörde die seit ihrer gründung in der
kritik steht
tatsache ist die mutter hat ihre beiden
kinder getötet
wie aber konnte es soweit kommen hätte
die tat verhindert werden können und
inwiefern trägt die behörde eine
mitverantwortung
[Musik]
also bei 70 und in der cloud oder zum
teil ist meine größte ganze sache ist
sehr wichtig für ganz harte opfer der
krise
[Musik]
am morgen des 4 november ist 2014 wurden
natalie kaiser und ihr ehemann bei einer
verdeckten polizeiaktion verhaftet und
in untersuchungshaft genommen
[Musik]
top ist eine option wäre dass wir so
krings wo es keine gesetzlich auch ganz
klar ja also ich kann es auch das ist
sehr schön mit älteren ob er okay
verstandes sagen dass ein konflikt gebe
mit dem sieg haben wir natürlich
rotierte hier wohne ist eine dritte
meint als büro und dann haben wir es
ganz büro im schlafzimmer gestopft alles
und handelns dem thema das kinderzimmer
eingerichtet oder jemand sagt ich habe
jetzt so ist dann ist das bag kaltenbeck
engagiert und möbel und kollegin hat
nach climategate creme der gewinn
komplett aus brake bild auch alles
andere kann man buchen
kritik richtet alles so ist müssen wir
umso und integrin da gehe aber was nützt
es hat sich als neue option das kind so
ist mit der 78 jährige jetzt wirklich
gerne machen sie es nicht kommen bei und
tod
[Musik]
verhaftet wurden die eltern der kinder
wegen verdachts auf gewerbsmäßigen
betrug und urkundenfälschung
die an kaiser vermutet dass man abklären
wollte ob seine tochter an den
betrügereien ihres mannes beteiligt war
also speziell also irgendwie im bild ist
kürzlich zum schluss gekommen
[Musik]
aber sie empfehlungen und sorgen gemacht
habe zuletzt wirklich so einfach
ein optimales glaubten was erzählt haben
von uns gegangen ist
vielleicht irgendwie ist nicht ganz so
komisch zu stehen hat sowie der aber
völlig browser e books lesen und dann
aber sache wo man sagen wo wir stehen
paul wallot entwicklungschancen konfuser
gemacht
als frau stück liebe halt mit hosen und
ein einfaches für das ist so wie wenn
wir mit dem fernziel hat die typische
familie damit mit hus und holt und pohl
und der realität ich hoffe es
in den wochen nach der verhaftung
wohnten die kinder im heim die
großeltern durften sie dort zwei mal die
woche besuchen um dieses wochenende
nahmen sie die kleinen mit zu sich nach
hause und hunger handschlaufe vereins
was nicht sicher können veränderte die
haben wir dann nach immer mehr worden
dass lee hat dann also ob er einfach da
ist plötzlich vor allem einen grund
darauf die haben heute kreiert und hat
einen echten hingucker hoch aber daran
erklärte der trainer
[Musik]
jetzt sprechen
und wieso das gespräch die flanken und
geschlossen ist
termine was machst du jetzt genau ist
das hat den her seit die ganze zeit hat
das kann man nur darum knappen ja
erhöht worden
es kostet und hat er exakt oder als da
hätte es krieg also das wirklich ein
paar songs eingerichtet
[Musik]
und trotzdem durften die kinder einige
tage vor weihnachten wieder nach hause
das hin und her schien endlich vorbei zu
sein und die familie schöpfte hoffnung
doch kurz darauf verfügte die kest dass
die kinder nach den festtagen wieder ins
heim zurückgebracht werden müssen laut
björn kaiser ohne ersichtliche
begründung die beschwerde die die
rechtsanwältin der mutter auf diesen
entscheid hinein reichte wurde vom
bezirksrat winterthur am 31 dezember
abgewiesen
novelle idee hat oder machen
acht monate nachdem natalie kaiser ihre
kinder getötet hatte nahm sie sich in
ihrer gefängniszelle das leben
die für den fall flach zuständige kess
winterthur andelfingen konnte zu diesem
zeitpunkt aus datenschutzrechtlichen
gründen keine stellungnahme zu den
ereignissen geben
stellvertretend versucht christoph
heffley seine sicht darzulegen häfele
ist jurist und sozialarbeiter und gilt
als einer der gründerväter der casp die
2013 die damalige vormundschaftsbehörde
abgelöst hat er war maßgeblich am
gesetzgebungsprozess des neuen kindes
und erwachsenenschutz rechts beteiligt
ohne das klettern was da passiert ist
einfach bin ich als erstes natürlich
absolut geschockt sie und die heftige
reaktionen sind vor allem natürlich
immer deinen strategie wenn es hinter
betrifft sind wo beteiligt sind aber
eine ganze problematik dass erschüttere
die erde dann ist zu gut dass das erst
im zweiten jahr von origins und
erwachsenenschutz nicht sie ist und
greift und recht schon monatelang
eigentlich im schussfeld der kritik sie
sind und das ist das letzte woche
brauchen besondere situation
und trotzdem muss man sagen das wird
auch wenn der crash und das neue recht
aber hoch akzeptiert sind umso besser
funktionieren da sie jetzt sind wieder
passieren kann so einige ereignisse
nicht wirklich hundertprozentig
verhindere
[Musik]
ich komme ich unterdrücke bezeichnet die
familie die tierhändler anblick eines
tier wird zur posse
[Musik]
muss ich jetzt das tier ok und verdi
stammte vielleicht manchmal stimmen ob
und wie ist es routine wieder vorüber
und wenn ich dich wirklich du okay
könnten normale familie
[Musik]
der mediale blick in den alltag einer
kiste ist heikel
einerseits aus datenschutzrechtlichen
gründen andererseits weil der fall flach
das ansehen der cas stark beeinträchtigt
hat dabei sind die einzelnen behörden
kantonal verwaltet und von einander
unabhängig die kest gosau im kanton st
gallen die also in den fall flach nicht
involviert ist war bereit uns einen
einblick zu gewähren und eine ahnung
davon zu vermitteln wie komplex die
fälle sind die sie betreuen polizei
häuslicher gewalt zu unterdessen und
laufen wieder ihre häusliche gewalt der
polizei ausrücken ist sexy dass der
partner von der mutter mutter bedroht
hat geschlagen hat und sogar noch
versucht massiven zwerge situation ist
so dass der partner nöte lieblich
vermeintlich und das sind
betriebe vier männer arbeitslos und
offenbar genug alkohol und die deren
situation jetzt der übliche quote sie
dass alkohol im spiel ist gelaufen
genau das eine ist sie das bundesamt mit
das gespräch kam
das ist natürlich hast du bist du also
insgesamt einfach in einer gruppe
tiffany druck nach einiger zeit aber
kein spiel aus und fast das ganze
gespräch angst dass mir jetzt lieber
etwas kinderschutzbehörde zeigt jetzt
muss das kind werken platziert werden
das haben wir gut mit ihr besprechen
ich glaube dass die kindergartenkinder
und sie hat weiß dass der stiefvater
oder der partner von der mutter
überhaupt keine rolle spielt also recht
begriff das meiste von dem gar nie
erzählt sie zeichneten
der hund der rolle spielen nicht
verwundet wochenende verteidigen nicht
vor da wird gar nie erwähnt ich weiß
nicht immer wieder heißt also ich an
mehrmals jetzt versucht dies laut einer
sie telefonisch und schriftlich unter
den ich bis jetzt nicht erschienen
er hat wird problem mit der behörden
offenbar dass ihnen erfahrungen gemacht
und jetzt räume mehrerer und wände bis
negativ dass man auch erklären dass es
andrea unterstütze ich sage bäurer und
wenn es so langer zeit irgendwo sich
laut 617 bereich versucht aber sehr
damit gewalt
das meer der größte nach so gern wieder
zurück
das analyse absichtlich so galt es nicht
unbedingt die beistandschaft sachen
damit einen schritt weiter sagt marc in
bester ordnung
das team der kest gossau ist wie alle
kinder und erwachsenen schutz behörden
in der schweiz interdisziplinär
zusammengestellt aus juristen
psychologen und sozialarbeitern im
letzten jahr betreute das team knapp 800
maßnahmen im erwachsenen- und
kindesschutz davon 30 fälle von fremd
platzierungen die schwierigste situation
sind für mich interschutz fällen muss
mit psychisch krank geld als torrent das
ist ein sehr schwerer mit den ex
kommunizieren und das sich und ahne dass
es darin schlecht geht und dass man mir
ein zimmer für bessere gesuche die
themenvielfalt chauvi heimreise planen
die grüne verwüstungen weg finden und
die frage beschäftige diamond natürlich
lang und auch allenfalls denn die hai
und die kleine situationen bin ich froh
dass ich nur die eigene sondern dass ihr
team haben das fahrzeug und riss
besprechen den weg finden
tatsächlich ist es so dass krisenzeit
schwierig sind beringt und je nach dam
und mit welchem personal darauf drehte
er drei aspekte im vordergrund stelle
besonders schwierig ist es wenn wir
jetzt gegen frauen ein held oder ganzen
und war nämlich von situation hand
auflegt und dann ist es natürlich
gezwungenermaßen fast so dass irgendwo
oder sich verletzt wird und so hat
priorität
der fall flach löste in der bevölkerung
eine welle der empörung und des
mitgefühls aus viele betroffenen
begannen sich in leserbriefen oder foren
über ihre eigenen probleme mit der
behörde zu äußern
so auch die familie merker aus ebnat
kappel im kanton st gallen
[Musik]
vor einem jahr wurde ihre älteste
tochter von der cas fremdplatziert sie
ist heute 17 und lebt bei einer
pflegefamilie in einem nachbardorf
ich habe mich ist das gut was bin ich
für den roboter das am 1
[Musik]
mein opa oder hustet hat bin ich
zusammen gefahren
rundum wohl angst um sie nicht hin dass
die restlichen vier wochen pausieren
die lage sei ja wie das ist jetzt die
man hat mir gesagt dass ich das für
einige die schon selber schuld und wir
haben wirklich tierisch darüber
geschrieben mit trauben mutter die
merkers haben fünf kinder
die jüngeren drei stammen aus der
jetzigen ehe von bea und daniel berger
die älteren beiden aus einer früheren
beziehung der mutter daniel merker
arbeitet ganztags in einem baugeschäft
wie am erker ist hausfrau und verdient
nebenbei ein wenig geld mit ihren selbst
gebastelten holzdekorationen dazu
[Musik]
die fremdplatzierung der ältesten
tochter kostet die eltern monatlich 5000
franken
geld das die merkers nicht haben die
kosten werden von der gemeinde
übernommen
daimler hat carlo schmitz und forderte
geld und geil dass ich weiterhin würde
ich nur noch für karstadt um das
finanzieren und ja es ist extrem schlimm
will ist es fällt es fällt wirklich ein
großer teil von geld und muss sind die
schwimmer dass wir ein hohes schmiert
lieber auf ihr die auch interessenten
entwickler dass das dass ich ihn über
land kaum zwei alltag stattfindet
mit der pubertät kam es zwischen den
eltern und der ältesten tochter nennen
wir sie es immer häufiger zu konflikten
die situation wurde immer schwieriger
und und ich denke ich als wie viel muss
ich mir vor wie im vorjahr wieviel
demütigungen könnten bis ich als mensch
als als ich selber dran sagen bis dahin
wo ich die ganze bereits mit 15 war es
für drei tage von zu hause weggelaufen
worauf die polizei und später die cas
eingeschaltet wurde für ein halbes jahr
erhielt die familie dann eine
beistandschaft die hier helfen sollte
wieder besser miteinander umzugehen
doch geholfen habe das wenig meint
beatrice berger für mich die wichtigste
grünen als einzigen sie darüber hatte
ich dir
terror kriege für tochter es war es mehr
als eine ohrfeige
sie lief erneut von zu hause weg und
zeigte ihren stiefvater bei der polizei
an
diesmal intervenierte die kest mit einer
superprovisorischen massnahmen und
platzierte die junge frau auf eigenen
willen in eine pflegefamilie
aber fühlen sie sich auch verantwortlich
für das was geschehen ist
immerhin die ohrfeige ich freue mich ja
aber ich vom verhältnis finde ich es
völlig sagt jetzt blöd sind dass ein
solches chaos lösen schloss am ende ja
völlig unverhältnismäßig für mich
unverständlich
ja heißt ich mich sehr strikt und ja es
ist beschissen hält dorfe gestoppt für
sie schlimm sei weil der papa nicht so
fern
der hat mir jetzt einfach eine
geschmiert und ich dann irgendwie in das
loch kite und so reagiert und ich schaue
ich kann nur vermutungen aufstellen muss
ich weiß es
es will sich im film nicht über ihre
situation äußern
per e-mail gab sie aber zu verstehen
dass sie an ihrer version der geschichte
festhält
ihr stiefvater habe ihr gedroht und sie
geschlagen
bis auf weiteres möchte sie deshalb
nicht zurück in ihre familie das dass
michael wieder haha ich ruhe und dann
klebte ja immer nah aber schauen dass
wir jetzt akzeptiert und haben sie
wieder los glaubt dass ich meine tochter
das beliebte ich geredet wo sie braucht
und ich gemerkt zu dem zeitpunkt wo
nichts los klarheit für mich selber acht
märkten sieht nicht so ist und das merkt
man dass die fichte musste fiel auf dass
sie mit flaggen natürlich ist geschafft
die mannschaft zum geboten
ich merke das sage ich zu euch und jetzt
mal wären das dann zu stark rund 50
wieder rank nicht und dann schließt
genau wie die anderen user das ist dann
alles wieder krank
ich wünsche mir schon dass die wir ja
dass sie wie bela entschuldigen muss
sich eigentlich nicht groß ich denke
dass wir mit getan
das weiß dass wir sie lieben und dass
man sie vermisst oder weniger gezogen
und ich bin aber überzeugt dass wir uns
zunächst als familie ja
was wäre sondern weniger wunsch wo sie
hand des rats vom 3
das ja wieder in familie ist dass wir
alles alte liebe wieder hin
ohne den ganzen ärger ohne die die
seelische schmerz psychische schmerz und
aus finanziellem ihm ehrlich sie ja
einfach harmonisch ist wirklich familie
leben zurück drei reisen etwas wehren
wunsch zukunft ein realistisches
unrealistische wunsch die wahrheit ans
licht kommt dass sie alles zum guten
wendet dass man den entscheid revidiert
dass man überhaupt nägel mit köpfen
macht und alles wieder zusammenbringt
das ist alles jetzt die behörde schuldig
das entschuldigt
aufgrund der datenschutz regelung kann
sich die kest toggenburg nicht äußern
deshalb kann hier nicht beurteilt werden
was genau geschehen ist tatsache ist die
behörde hat ihn kindes willen
respektiert und versucht im interesse
des kindes zu handeln also ein älterer
mann jetzt einen massiven eingriff der
kinder wächst oder vor betroffen sind
unglücklich sind würdig sind ist das
absolut verständlich und nachvollziehbar
obwohl das ziel ist aber prozess die
ältere mit schnee so dass sie möglichst
auf mindestens und akzeptiere die welt
schwer begeistert sie wenn man die
massive griff macht aber dann ich selber
ziel sowohl von der behörde als auf den
bestand wo regelmäßig gesetzt wird wenn
man für eine platzierung gemacht mit der
ältere zäsur gewinn verlust siegemund
erfüllt sie damit das kind wieder
zurückkommt sondern eher das ist der
gesamte auftrag und nicht einfach hinter
dem schuss ferne dass ich vielleicht ja
gut problemsituationen sagen das macht
aber nach einer luke man ja wir haben
wir die ältere www.cdu wanne es sicher
vor wenn das kind platziert werden zweck
familie oder in
danach eine ist entsorgen und dann
wendet man sich mit einer neuen aufgabe
zu
aber es ist nicht im sinn vom erfinder
es ist nicht professionell platz felix
machen und älter hauptschüler ja großer
sich portman oder tochter ganz viele ich
wieder im fall richtig konnte wobei ich
finde einfach mehr hätten
mal mit all seiner das thematisieren das
haben wir gemacht will das was mir noch
jeder achte klasse hat irgendwer 34
nicht sperrt sich schon wahnsinn was da
ihnen anklopfen ist ohne dass man mit
uns über das gerät als mir hand 434
meldet sich nicht gewusst dass mir heute
tochter jetzt in der hand warum das sie
fremdplatziert wurden nicht unter dienst
timeout zsc
und nun schon das zeigt uns dass chris
brown interessiert ist das überhaupt
richtig lese ich hätte man das konya
kommuniziert was der grund ist meine
gesetze kommt jetzt immer high und
fertig auch das kann hier nicht
verifiziert werden
die schwierige situation zu hause sowie
das familiendrama in flaach waren für
daniel merker aber auslöser etwas gegen
die kest zu unternehmen
er gründete eine antike website und fand
schnell großen zuspruch unzählige
gleichgesinnte und betroffene meldeten
sich viele baden um hilfe und rat
praktisch über nacht wurden die merkers
zur drehscheibe einer schweizweiten
bewegung
[Musik]
wichtige betragen
im sommer 2015 wurde in küssnacht im
kanton schwyz offiziell die initiative
zur abschaffung der cas klassiert das
sogenannte subsidiaritätsprinzip erst
mantra familie könige mehr bereit sind
den gründungs komitee steht
svp-nationalrat pirmin schwander vor
er erhielt prominente unterstützung von
der schriftstellerin jenny sowie der
psychologin julia onken
[Musik]
[Applaus]
und so begann sich widerstand zu
formieren
in der ganzen deutschschweiz kam es zu
größeren und kleineren kundgebungen
gegen die kest
[Musik]
unsere pflicht diese gefangenen kindern
endlich eine stimme
und für sie prozent
viele der demonstranten sehen sich
selbst als opfer der behörde eltern die
gegen die fremdplatzierung ihrer kinder
protestieren
senioren die sich in ihren
persönlichkeitsrechten eingeschränkt
fühlen oder jugendliche die ihre
negativen heim erfahrungen zum ausdruck
bringen
ein junger mann die sorge was problem
wurde heinrich schlagen auf der straße
und der grundriss 1
doch sage mir dass sehen mal erklären
was es bringt doch das heim dass der
ganze scheiß die heime verschwinden
worte tiefen hinter situationen verstört
und mutter so finnisch oder wasser
verschluckt sich hilfe und untersander
team nun ich erinnere dich als
kritischer worte wie du marina
schleuniger ist arbeitslos und
alleinerziehende mutter von drei kindern
ihr freund martin hilft ihr beim umzug
die junge mutter musste in den letzten
jahren immer wieder umziehen
überforderung beziehungs und
alkoholprobleme führten dazu dass sich
vor einem jahr die kest einschaltete und
die kinder im heim platzierte und das
tat sie nicht zum ersten mal bereits
2011 hatte die damalige
vormundschaftsbehörde die kinder
fremdplatziert da hatte ich die aber
nicht beantragen
doch gerade nach dem todesfall und kurz
klinik hohles hatte kaiser psychologe
stark suizidgefährdet dass ich dann aber
doch zwei tage ist das vor der klinik
wieder leid wurde und es ist möglich
eine gurke und da zieht sie die kinder
sein
das für mich um schlink sie das wirklich
der todesfall sondern ein stück ganz
wurden oder vier sagt zu geworden
am schlimmsten ist dass man weiß kind
fragen sich wo ich zwar nie war ich
passiert um reine kulturkreis nicht
beruhigen
einfach mitmachen nach diesem ersten
zwischenfall durften die kinder wieder
nach hause
doch farina schleuniger ist leben wurde
nicht einfacher drei jahre später kam es
zu einem erneuten vorfall erzählt sie
ich habe zwar relativ viel druck und
daran haben hilft zu achten
daraufhin informierte die polizei
drei wochen später wurden die kinder aus
der schule geholt und ein zweites mal
ins heim gebracht
seither versucht farina schleuniger zu
belegen dass sie ihr leben wieder im
griff hat
[Musik]
bis aber zu der sucht fachstellen für
unregelmässige atemluft 60 an klar
kontrolliert werde ich habe bestätigen
versuch stellt das zahlt das kraut hohe
abhängigkeit daran war ich gebracht
haben die bemühungen der jungen mutter
nichts die kinder sind seit fast einem
jahr im heim und werden auch weiterhin
dort bleiben müssen wenn ja warum so
mutig sie betont ich habe immer darauf
geachtet alles belege hat die mädels ich
belegte das gut ist desto könnte ich die
rinde und das ist aber leider nicht der
fall
minute vollständigen sie nicht das
einzige wo nicht nur kurz nach dem
todesrad erzählte ist auf 20 personen
gestorben
das heißt trauen so starke familie ich
einen moment und ich bin ja studio
vorstand egon stars in jeden sonntag
holt farina schleuniger ist stiefvater
die kinder mit dem auto aus dem heim ab
damit die vier möglichst viel zeit
miteinander verbringen können
hinter dem fremde holte dann heim oder
redaktionelle port integriert mich jetzt
nicht wieder unsere wieder ineinander so
wie du mir aber mit einem gern
auseinander setzen
ich halte ich ihn vor und es ist kein
grund zum die länger da zahlte für mich
haben jetzigen zeitpunkt ist es einfach
freiheitsberaubung dass er an ort
festhalten werde sagt sich tötet aber am
abend dazu nach den frauen die angst was
ich wann die zahlen aber wir sind auch
hier darf die zuständige casp st gallen
ihre überlegungen und die hintergründe
zur heim platzierung der kinder aus
datenschutzrechtlichen gründen nicht da
liegen jede wo es sehen job nicht
richtig erfüllt oder laptop vom
erzieherinnen kaum erfüllen
tesche mal im grund natürlich
unglücklich darüber wenn uns frieden
aber er sucht natürlich um nach
rechtfertigungen warum es nicht läuft
und die kutsche und da funktionieren wir
alle krieg mit tendieren natürlich dazu
der grund verschickten irgendwie war
begeben
peter schwenkow
pp profis wo sich prämiert das ist ein
absolut keine geo normale reaktion und
kunst von der profis wozu hat mit einem
mit werden die luetkens konfrontieren
mit dem eigenanteil arbeite misere und
mit ihnen zweimal nach weg suchen wie
sie wie man die han reduzieren so dass
wir natürlich eine funktion die ich
glaube dass ich sowieso niemand gern hat
das würden wir genau gleich gar nicht
rassistisch war das um ist sie
öffentlich machen das natürlich dann das
so werden auch die ausgelieferten sie
auslösen auch nicht gut verstaut und das
vor dem herd und der reflexion tag tritt
man mit einer behörde am liebsten ist
dankbar was ich mache nein gegenteil ich
komme gern zur arbeit und bin auch ich
dass das im vorjahr bei tisch und
letztlich von vielen geschätzt wird
am anfang wenn wir über keiner werd ich
mich auch schwierig ist jetzt das bild
gemacht und wer ich bin wenn ich
funktioniere
meine kollegen in der sendung kollegen
und deiner klasse der regel ganz
automatisch und hatte wieder von den
betroffenen wenn ihr wirklich ganz alte
entscheide und mit regel auf das viel
direkter und persönlicher und
entspannter als in den medien
dargestellt wird
im letzten jahr ist viel negatives über
kreis berichtet worden ist dass bio auch
so was hat das bravourös gelöst ist
sicher nicht immer einfach vivendi sa
petrofac sprachen händler von christ und
menschen so viel negativ sie bereich
gehört dass ich den augen das muss ich
auch können erklären
auch eine luft zeige dass moment nur die
böse sind
es ist ja nicht so dass man wenn man
meldungen
denn so familie gönnt und das kind aus
der familie nehmen sondern seine miete
familie und umfeld wie es abu dhabi
machen helfen und medial das kind spielt
er am tiber was müsste man damit
vermittlung das negative bild jetzt
korrigieren
also ich persönlich würde mir wünschen
dass die leute wenn sie negative
berichte in den medien hören oder auch
lesen dass ihnen bewusst ist dass es in
jedem fall verschieden wahrnehmung gibt
oder auch verschiedene perspektiven und
wir von der geest wir reden ja auch mit
dem umfeld der regen dann mit lehrern
oder auch mit schulsozialarbeitern oder
mit ärzten wir hören dann eben
verschiedene perspektiven wie die wir
über den fall zu hören bekommen
darum wäre es eben wirklich auch mein
wunsch dass den leuten sie differenziert
dass algen und dass sie sich auch
überlegen was steckt dahinter
es ist nur eine meinung die sie gehört
haben aber eben es gibt vielleicht auch
vieles was sie nicht gehört haben was
wir auch aufgrund des amtsgeheimnis
nicht sagen dürfen
monatelang wurden die komplexen
zusammenhänge des falls flach durch
unabhängige gutachter untersucht ende
januar 2016 wurden die ergebnisse von
der zürcher justiz direktorin jacqueline
fehr präsentiert das handeln und die
entscheide der kinder und
erwachsenenschutz behörde winter an
geringen waren allesamt vertretbar das
verfahren war in vielen teilen gut und
sogar vorbildlich es gab aber auch
mängel
diese sind erkannt benannt und die
korrekturen sind in die wege geleitet
die tat war nicht vorhersehbar und damit
wohl auch nicht verhinderbar die täterin
trug das potenzial zur tat in sich
weder das neue umfeld noch die behörden
konnten die gefahr
damit ist auch klar selbst wenn dies
alles perfekt gemacht hätte wäre es wohl
zu dieser tat gekommen
es gibt damit keinen ursächlichen
zusammenhang zwischen dem handeln der
behörden und dieser extrem
[Musik]
muster medicom verein zu sein ist
eigentlich dass sie keine schuld 3g
crash für 12 heißt da sagt man euch dass
sie kräftig dreieck hat einen ganzen
gehören zur tragödie einmal fangen
geräte miteinander sowie co
das gutachten bringt ja klar
kommunikationsmängel auf den tisch das
dann komme ich so was nicht gefällt ist
dass man quasi einfach sei es ist
trotzdem arctic sea wie die
kommunikationsmittel wie handy anschluss
eigentlich dachte ich strebe das jetzt
mal provokativ wenn man hätte ich ihnen
erkläre was wir wo warum der situation
anders aus holz zu einer pizza hut ist
das schlusswort einer dass man die
tabletten verhindere oder was die tat
eventuell sogar was wohl passiert wäre
meine space berechtige reagiert die erde
und das ist mir total einig sind
denn die sind bereits über hätten wir
das gar nicht wie co
[Musik]
also ich habe großes verständnis für die
vorwürfe großeltern will ich mir bewusst
wäre unglaublich schwierige situation
die großeltern sind trotzdem zeigen alle
wenn frage sind das stück wird
tatsächlich hypothetisch wenn der vater
kein betrug sie war
wenn es nicht zu der heftig aber wenn
man das gespräch anders oder so führt
etwa wahrscheinlich eine andere
situation geschaffen worden wo viel
licht auch zu einer anderen geschichte
geführt
tatsache ist aber dass letztlich
ausgelöst worden ist
foto motto wo nötig alex ist aufgrund
ihrer krankheit schrecklichkeit von
deren idee gründungs bringen zu können
wo andere hätten könne die idee
verworfen hat sie es nicht können und
die strom zur tat schritten
[Musik]
der vorschlag und die uvs passiert ist
bisher führt mit sicherheit sondern
erhöhte sensibilisierung vor allem in
dem bereich tätig sind und trotzdem ist
es illusorisch meinem enorme
professionalität und noch besser werden
als ohne die katastrophe verhindert es
lebe ich einfach so verrückt dass wir
erfahrene lüth wo ihre top sehr gut
macht trotzdem risiko laufen wieder mal
mit seiner situation konfrontiert werde
[Musik]
liga
jährlich werden in der schweiz an die
1000 kinder fremdplatziert für die
meisten betroffenen sind das schwieriger
traumatische erlebnisse das ist die eine
seite der wahrheit
schwieriger wird es über die andere
seite der wahrheit zu berichten
wie viele kinder wurden dank der kest
geschützt wie viele familien entlastet
was wäre aus einem kind geworden wenn es
nicht fern platziert sondern zu hause
geblieben wäre
auf der schwierigen suche nach antworten
darf nicht vergessen werden worum es in
erster linie geht um den schutz der
kinder
[Musik]
doch mit dem neuen toyota rav4 firma 4
und hybrid die ideale kombination für
die schweiz